where the raiders have been hit by the  virus more players on the nfl's coveted  watch list look at this list right here  the raiders  on this list right here doesn't mean now  they're all ruled out for sunday's game  with the chiefs  outside of cleveland farrell some of  these guys may have just been in close  proximity so the rest of this group here  may be allowed to play if they continue  to test  negative no word from the nfl if they  plan on moving that game now remember  the writers already had the  plug polled on the last time they were  featured on a sunday night game  coming up at five we'll have more on the  actual game the defending super bowl  champions  are visiting las vegas and what is john  gruden saying about back up running back  devonta  booker and they've liked the former utah  youth for quite a while brian